هنا السويد وهنا يسمع الغضب التركي
لوزير الدفاع السويدي الى انقره اخر
الاسبوع فهذا ما قرر هوتراك
فلاحظنا بكل اسف ان السلطات لم تتخذ اي
اجراء بشان تلك الافعال الحقيره والمثيره
لشمزاز التي ارتكب ضد بلدنا ورئيسنا رغم
مطالبتنا اياهم بذلك بالتالي لم تعد تلك
الزياره التي كان من المقرر ان يقوم بها
وزير الدفاع السويدي الى انقره في السابع
والعشرين من الشهر الجاري ذات معنى فلذلك
الغناء
يشير اكور الى تحركات جماعات كرديه
المناوله لانقر ونيت معا على الاراضي
السويديه
ومما اثار الحلقه التركيه ايضا ترخيص
الشرطه السويديه لمظاهره الامام السفاره
التركيه في ستوكهولم احرق خلالها ناشط
يمني متطرف نسخه من المصحف الشريف
[موسيقى]
بعضها اثار احتجاجات مضاده عنيفه
جرائم الكراهيه ليست حريه تعبير يقول وزير
الخارجيه التركي
فحريه التعبير هو التبرير الذي تسوقه
السلطات السويديه لترخيصها مظاهرات على
اراضيها ومع ذلك يصف وزير الخارجيه
السويدي الاستفزازات المعاديه للاسلام
بانها مروعه
وطبعا وزير الدفاع السويدي بالجونسون
فيحرص على بياني ان علاقه بلاده مع تركيا
مهمه للغايه لكنه لا يشير الى التاثيرات
المحتمله للازمه الاخيره على مساعد دوله
الاسكندنافيه للانضمام الى حلف شمال
الاطلسي ما زال الاتراك يشددون على ضروره
تنفيذ الالتزامات الوارده في المذكره
الثلاثيه الموقعه في مدريد في يونيو
الماضي بين تركيا والسويد وفنلندا تنص
المذكره على تسليم اشخاص تعتبرهم تركيا
ارهابيين وعلى حظر عمل احزاب وتنظيمات
تدرجها على قوائم الارهاب
انها اوفت بكل تعاهدات التي قدمتها لانقره
فيما يتعلق بالانضمام لناتوب ولذلك ينبغي
فيما ترى اي يعجل الاتراك بالتصديق على
تلك العضويه التي تنشدها فنلندا ايضا لكن
تركيا تعتقد ان السويد على الاخص تحتاج
لعمل المزيد حتى تزول عنها التحفظات واذا
كانت مساله اللحاق بركب الناتو في الاساس
معقده مع تمسك الاتراك بمقتضيات امنهم
القومي فالان يبدو ان ما يصدر من اعراض
السويد من استفزازات كما تسميها انقره او
قاعه انتكاستا بهذا المسار